es klingt wie der sound eines science
fiction thrillers doch für die fachleute
der nasa ist diese historische messung
ein entscheidender meilenstein
die rede ist von der faszinierenden
aufnahmen die der nasa-sonde inside
gelungen ist wenn bei dem zittern wie
die forschungsteams es bezeichnet
handelt es sich höchstwahrscheinlich um
ein erdbeben auf dem roten planeten
klick zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen es war der
128 tag der mars mission von insight am
6 april hatte das seismische instrument
der nasa-sonde das rauschen
aufgezeichneten experten der nasa
bezeichnen es als zittern und sind
restlos begeistert kein wunder denn
schließlich handelt es sich bei diesem
zittern aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach um
die allererste aufnahme eines erdbebens
auf dem mars laut nasa eine historische
messung und somit ein spektakulärer
erfolg auf solch ein signal habe man
schon seit monaten gewartet der
seismograph seismik experiment forint
area structure kurz ice wurde von der
französischen weltraumbehörde anderen
national d'etudes spezial cms entwickelt
und befindet sich schon seit dezember
2018 auf dem mars das instrument horst
quasi in den roten planeten hinein um
erschütterung zu registrieren und ist
dabei von den extremen winden und
temperaturschwankungen auf dem roten
planeten geschützt sei es hat in den
vergangenen monaten schon drei
ausschläge messen können die analyse
dieser messung dauert noch an doch nach
ansicht der forschungsteams hatte es
sich dabei höchstwahrscheinlich
lediglich um viel wind gehandelt doch
das sei bei der zuletzt detektierten
erschütterung etwas anderes dazu der
insight experte bus bannert wir haben
bisher hintergrundgeräusche gesammelt
doch dieses ereignis markiert offiziell
den beginn eines neuen forschungsfeldes
erdbeben kunde das maß auch wenn noch
kein endgültiger beweis dafür vorliegt
das nasa forschungsteam ist sich
ziemlich sicher dass das aufgezeichnete
zittern aus dem mars inneren stammt die
veröffentlichte aufnahme enthält auch
noch andere geräusche die die experten
und expertinnen dem mars wind und dem
roboter ab zuordnen dennoch stellt das
delektiert beben die experten und
expertinnen vor große rätsel wo liegt
sein ursprung und wie ist es entstanden
schließlich besteht der mars aus nur
eine einzige platte
das leben kann also anders als die
meisten erdbeben auf der erde nicht
durch die verschiebung von
kontinentalplatten zustande gekommen
sein
das erklärt jedoch auch warum das maß
beben im vergleich zu einem beben auf
der erde extrem schwach ist hier auf der
erde hätten wir es wohl nicht einmal
bemerkt die nasa fachleute gehen bislang
davon aus dass risse in der mars küste
aufgebrochen sind und für die
erschütterung gesorgt haben solche risse
entstehen wenn der planet abkühlt auch
wenn das jetzt gemessene maß beben er
klein war und noch wirklich keine
soliden erkenntnisse über den aufbau des
planeten liefert macht das hoffnung auf
mehr
denn die auszeichnung belegt dass das
instrument tatsächlich sensibel genug
ist um selbst solche schwachen
erschütterung zu registrieren fachleute
hoffen dass pro monat etwa ein beben mit
einer ähnlichen stärker registriert
werden kann dazu christiana vom st
wir sind begeistert von diesem ersten
erfolg und freuen uns darauf weitere
solche messungen in den kommenden jahren
zu bekommen und damit könnten wir
endlich den aufbau und die vorgänge im
inneren des roten planeten verstehen
denn die ausbreitung der seismischen
wellen lässt rückschlüsse über die
materialien zu aus denen kruste mantel
und kern bestehen übrigens gelang es der
nasa vor fast fünf jahrzehnten mit genau
dieser technik den aufbau des mondes zu
verstehen durch die analyse einiger
tausend beben auf dem mond im zeitraum
zwischen 1969 und 1972 konnten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nämlich die einzelnen schichten des
mondes ermitteln sind erde und mond
dasselbe anklicken anschauen und
natürlich neugier zonen abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran